I want to start our
conversation talking about the ruling in
the Texas case because it really Cuts
right to the heart of what these laws
are all about it it def it defines the
law here quickly as restricting access
to pornographic websites by requiring
digital age verification methods and
warnings about the alleged harms caused
by
pornography the warnings aspect of this
is uh kind of interesting and amusing uh
that these are some examp of the
warnings that must be posted in 14o font
or larger Texas Health and Human
Services warning pornography is
potentially biologically addictive and
proven to harm human brain development
exposure to this content is associated
with low self-esteem and Body Image
pornography increases the demand for
prostitution child exploitation and
child
pornography then here's the kicker the
judge notes that although These Warnings
carry the label Texas Health and Human
Services it appears that the Texas
Health and Human Services Commission has
not made these findings or
announcements so we could talk more
about the we're g to talk more about
what we do and don't know about the
effects of porn but one more thing I
want to pull uh in from the from the
judges ruling uh the it was a PR
preliminary Junction halting this law on
the grounds that compelled verification
chills protected speech um because first
the Restriction is constitutionally
problematic because it deters adults
access to legally explicit material far
beyond the interest of protecting minors
and it has races privacy concerns
because by requiring you to submit
government
identification and this information then
going into a government database you're
essentially giving the state a permanent
database of everyone's porn browsing
history with no mechanism requiring them
to delete it or who has access to it and
so forth so those are were among the
judges objections there were also things
like it was overly uh broad it did
things it did this in a way that was not
narrowly tailored uh in a way to protect
Free Speech but Aya what is
your reaction and response to this law
and the way that the porn industry has
reacted to it I mean like grief or
something and
disappointment um there's a way where a
lot of it's kind of conservative coded
has said a lot about oh um we like
Freedom uh don't turn on me uh let's say
out of each other's business um and
there's a way where I kind of hope they
meant it in a more principled manner uh
but instead we are saying that this only
applies for things that they approve of
but as soon as you're uh stepping on to
things that people find like personally
offensive which is why I assume is going
on here uh in suddenly like this
principles no longer apply um I'm really
glad that it doesn't seem to be that it
seems to be being successfully
challenged in some courts
though you know as someone who is a
Texas res
who's provided studied and consumed a
lot of online sexual material like what
are your biggest concerns about how it's
going to affect the
landscape yeah it depends so this is it
depends on like how much this affects
but like as with most things like for
example with escorting like you
introduce laws that try to prohibit some
things and it just shoves things
underground into places where you can't
uh you can't actually like be safe that
easily like with the back page thing
like they were working with um FBI
people to turn in like people who are
child molesters child Predators or
traffickers then the whole website went
down and then like boom your whole
access is gone um and so I think of
something very similar is happening here
like if you do want to track uh like bad
porn to some degree but see it's really
funny because like pornnhub is one of
the cleanest porn sites on the internet
like everybody ships on PornHub uh for
their content that they have but like as
somebody who tries to post foreign
places uh it's one of the most difficult
and most stringent websites um so a
little bit about that like what's the
what's the landscape I think most people
you know are maybe uh only fair weather
fans of porn sites and only do a little
bit of uh you know recreational PornHub
browsing but give us a little bit of a
sense of like what are some of the
characteristics of really bad actors in
This landscape and how might this wall
result in this unintended consequence of
boosting those Bad actors while
punishing PornHub
uh so like PornHub so if you are a porn
actor uh if you're publishing erotic
content on the internet for the past 10
to 20 years um what happens is you just
it's part of the process that some
people steal your stuff and publish it
online in places you didn't consent to
it's so normal that like we haven't even
processed it this is an issue because
like nobody gives a [__] about us like
about like controlling your content in
like copyright kind of ways um it's it's
s sort of an attitude like oh well if
you're going to be naked outside like
why you shouldn't expect any sort of
ability to control like the naked images
of you if you're doing this you're doing
it to yourself um and pornh was like one
of the only uh as far as I know they
weren't legally pressured into it at all
they started paying you for Content that
other people posted about you on their
platform um which to my awareness is the
first time that any porn site started
doing this and I was like holy [__]
you're treating us like humans you don't
support stolen content here um and
there's also the problem of fetishes
which is a different topic but PornHub
really doesn't allow fetishes that are
considered maybe a little bit uh edgy
for some people um like what are some
examples um like if you want uh like
like struggle [__] to some degree
which is a subreddit that was banned in
a a couple years ago um but this is like
more of a phenomenon of the cleansing of
fetishes from the entire internet um
like trans stuff trans fetishes is like
uh anything that like might be
considered sort of morally offensive to
people on the outside uh anything too
kinky um but anyway so like PornHub is
one of the wonderful ones that like
seems to actually pay performers in a
way where they were never forced to and
it seems such a shame that like that's
the thing being pressured underneath and
there's tons of websites that are just
people can post stolen content and you
can do absolutely nothing about it are
you disappointed in any sense that
PornHub the stance that they're taking
here is we support the law just we don't
like that it's only we're going to be
the only ones complying with it um
instead of taking a
more expansive or strident opposition to
the idea that this is a good way to
regulate or prevent children from
accessing pornography is is that what
they I thought they maybe I
misunderstood I thought they were like
we pull it up in a second here we
disapprove of uh the way this is I think
I thought they said they approve of like
trying to prevent minors from
accessing yeah uh let's see we've
started to introduce laws aimed at
preventing children from accessing
material harmful to minors online this
is okay yeah you're right they're saying
this they've supported that notion um if
not necessarily the the law itself so
yeah that's seems like yeah a very
publicly safe thing to say and a lot of
people like in good faith I think
support this I personally think that
we we are like way overly stringent
about kids
sexuality but I understand that PornHub
might
disagree there's a question I just saw
that kind of goes to this point Jason
chavaria says why not just have porn
sites on a separate domain than parents
can actually control access this was an
issue that was brought up in the lawsuit
is the idea that you could have
something like better content filtering
so that's what you know me as a parent
would want access to is just tools that
really enable me to have a bit more
control over what my kid can get to on
the internet and if there was a law that
had more to do with you know saying a
browser has to have a certain level of
content filtering or something like that
like still don't think that's ultimately
gonna that there's always going to be
workarounds but at least that would be
more theoretically defensible to most
well I just want to raise the VPN
objection here I mean yeah most
consumers of porn I would imagine are
basically like probably teenage boys up
to you know actual male adults um pretty
much everybody is technologically able
to use a VPN and so I'm curious about
like does this just slightly raise the
costs um of actually accessing porn but
like how airtight is this
what do you think
a yeah I don't people will find porn is
like one of the most powerful things and
if you're a teenage do you remember
being a teenage boy I remember it well
yeah you how how much do you think these
content filters would have stopped you I
yeah I you know this guy here Sandman
speaks to this point he says learn from
the War on Drugs you cannot ban anything
people will always find ways to get what
they want and there will be someone to
supply it and I agree with you a that
especially in a case where the the drive
is so strong people will find a way and
the way to do it is fairly easy and it
is VPN like everyone
knows most people
uh it's not that hard to download a VPN
um most people uh are technically able
to do it and certainly a you know
15-year-old boy who's a motivated enough
to uh get to it is going to figure out
that workaround um and and so I think in
some sense yeah we're going to just uh
like if if this trend continues uh that
you're going to just see it's going to
be a boon for the VPN industry uh and
I'm I'm fine with that but uh it's still
worth it you know in the interim to you
know we want to be if if we want a
maximally free world then
we want to be working we want to have
the the exit hatches like the vpns the
workarounds but also you know fighting
um and supporting fights on on the legal
front as well I want to yeah go
ahead I was going to say I feel like a
lot of this is coming from a misguided
place like to some degree I think we
should question the idea that we should
be protecting kids from exposure to
sexuality at all like like there's this
weird phenomenon where we're treating
teenagers like they don't have a sex
drive and like aren't shouldn't be
allowed any access to any sexual content
at all um and I'm like that's feels so
strange to me and and like dehumanizing
in a way I feel like ideally we should
be giving them sort of like sexual
content that they desperately want but
with a lot more education about it
they're gonna be doing it anyway what
does that look like like in your ideal
view of the world I assume that doesn't
mean trusting State Departments of educ
to appropriately administer sex ad right
I mean school is deeply [__] up as an
institution but if we had to use it I
would say like maybe have like a like in
your class about sexuality I'll have a
section on pornography be like hey here
are the incentives when people are
shooting porn the incentives are
different from the kinds of incentives
you have when you are having sex uh here
are examples of scenes and porn that you
should not be extrapolating to real life
um and I think like it's really
uncomfortable for us as adults to think
about doing this like with people who
are underage um but underage people are
people also they're legitimate people
with full sexualities and it's just like
feels insulting and dehumanizing to
treat them as anything else and that
proposed would have the positive
consequence of also teaching people
about incentives which we as
Libertarians can very much get behind
because that seems to be ignored in most
public schools these days uh but I am
curious I mean do you see um a place for
the sort of parental rights argument
that Zach is making like I think about
this you know I have a very young son
right now but navigating this in the
future I think think like well I I see
my role in his life as like this this
Steward of you know attempting to sort
of sus out as best I can which you know
admittedly probably won't be perfect a
sense of what type of material is age
appropriate and the ways to attempt to
provide behind the scenes context so
that he can develop healthier ways of
thinking about you know sexuality or or
violence in the world or processing
grief like any sort of hard thing I see
the role of the parent as sort of you're
this intermediary between the kid and
the outside world and you you take on
ideally less of that intermediary role
to some degree as they get older and as
you know they are more and more
independent but how do you look at that
tension between parental rights and also
as you said treating a minor like
they're a human too I mean like is the
question are there some parents that
don't treat their kids like humans well
I think I think the question of like if
if we place this firmly in the parental
rights Camp of like every parent ought
to to be able to decide for themselves
for their minor child under the age of
18 um you know what type of Internet
content they feel comfortable with them
accessing this creates a problem where
some parents will probably draw that
line in a really you know what you would
consider to be a bad spot so how do you
look at this in terms of like making
sexual material more pervasive for
underage children even if that means
sort of flouting the wishes of their
parents well I mean you can do both I
don't like you can do a thing you allow
parents to behave as they want with
their kids I guess public school is a
deeply [__] institution and I guess
that's hard because parents sort of have
to vote on what their kids are exposed
to I'm like a pro homeschooler
whatever way I'm gonna good company here
yeah yeah in my fantasy world it's like
we like people like us would go out and
do messaging like hey guys treat your
kids like
people and but we wouldn't I don't agree
with the use of force like I think
adults should be allowed to I see this
with a lot of like on discomfort but um
like I think parents should be allowed
to uh trying to say the words like treat
your child is subhuman but like it's
difficult say that I don't I really hate
it the only problem is I'm saying it's
because the alternative is so much worse
like it's like either the parents do or
the government does it hey thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with Aya about porn laws the sexual
Revolution and the freedom to browse the
internet privately and PE anonymously
you can watch another clip right here or
the full conversation over here